well there's so many people in prison
that sexual victimization in prison now
has come to constitute a significant
portion of the sexual victimization zin
society as a whole
Human Rights Watch and some other human
rights organizations have really began
in the late 90s documenting the
incredibly high rates of sexual assault
and which was not new if you go back and
look at the very economical
cost-effective regimented system that
Texas was able to perfect over the
course of the 20th century based on
convict guards a lot of the ways those
guards were in a sense compensated was
by a lot by officers turning a blind eye
to their sexual victimization of punks
so-called punks in prison so sexual
assault has been endemic and often a
tool of a tool of subjugation in prisons
for a very long time but it has gotten a
lot more attention and under the Bush
administration to the Bush
administration's credit they signed
legislation to kind of conduct a lot
more research into sexual victimization
and so we're getting a lot better a lot
better data on that now and I think
because the data is now available some
corrections officers are starting to
take it more seriously and therefore
when victims or would-be victims are in
a compromising situation we are
beginning to have a system in which they
feel like they can go to the authorities
and seek protection and receive redress
but we are frankly a long way from that
and there's of course a public health
component to this as well to both
coerced sex and and consensual sex in
prison and that is that another way that
mass imprisonment is adversely affecting
the public is that they have become
inked
vader's of public health problems they
become incubators of hepatitis-b they
become incubators of HIV and antibiotic
resistant tuberculosis and of course all
of that has consequences beyond prison
walls so it's a you know yet another
reason to try and use incarceration as a
penalty of last resort than a penalty of
first resort as we have started doing in
recent years
I don't know if we have seen a change in
the public mindset yet we we are we have
seen a leveling off of the prison
population in the last few years we have
seen a lot of states start to mitigate
some of the harsh steps they've taken
over the past two generations Texas has
rolled back partially the Rockefeller
drug laws California facing bankruptcy
is struggling to release 40,000 inmates
in order to comply with federal court
orders a lot of states are trying to
figure how to save money because of
because of the budget crisis by
downsizing these resource devouring
bureaucracies that they've built but I
don't know if we have yet seen a shift
in public attitudes that will probably
take in some ways there's there's
evidence that the harsh public attitudes
have been driven in some ways by
television and by politicians if you
look at a sociologists in Washington
Katherine Beckett kind of went back and
looked at opinion surveys you know how
seriously the public thought drug
addiction how serious of a problem that
was compared to other problems and she
found that for instance before Bush the
first brandishes bag of crack that had
been purchased in Lafayette Park and
made the war on drugs a central part of
his presidency before that political
leadership for partisan purposes took
place and commanded public attention the
public was not particularly concerned
about illegal drug use and afterwards
they developed harsher attitudes and
more anxiety so we're gonna have to see
some leadership in the other direction I
think for people to start developing
other ideas one thing I should say about
that too is that the public quite
understandably has very fickle attitudes
and and conflicted attitudes toward
crime and punishment as all of us do and
so polls are some ways driven by how you
ask the question so if you ask people do
we go to should we be harder on
criminals than we are
many poll recipients especially white
men that should be said will say yes we
need to be harder on crime but if you
ask them the public should we have
should we emphasize treatment over
incarceration for nonviolent drug crimes
they also so yes or should we have more
treatment in prison or should we have
more education in prisons so you know
framing has a lot to do with how
successfully we're able to pursue
changes problem we've had in recent
years is that the Democrats from the end
of the Johnson administration forward
have been running scared on criminal
justice they felt that the accusation of
being soft on crime was one of their
critical vulnerabilities and so
President Clinton more masterful
masterfully than his predecessors
decided that he was going to be as
draconian as any of his opponents and he
signed the largest harshest crime bills
in American history during his watch and
he did successfully fortify his right
flank
on criminal justice but with absolutely
disastrous effects and so far the Obama
administration has not taken that
approach of course they've had a
congressional majority so they haven't
had as much pressure to do so and we
will see whether they are able to have
the kind of fortitude and attention and
able to marshal the political capital to
kind of move through some serious
changes as as there's some evidence that
they do want to do